c'est un lieu où vous pourriez rester
presque toute une journée ce nouveau
centre de loisirs situé à montigny le
bretonneux et baptisé smiles world vient
d'ouvrir en ce début du mois de juillet
il a pris place dans les locaux des
anciens cinémas gaumont de l'espace 55
miles more en fait c'est un nouveau
groupe qui vient qui vient de se
construire on a déjà différents
établissements mais on se bat vraiment
sûr du loisir urbain
là on vient d'ouvrir le premier smile le
premier établissement qui appartient au
groupe maï qui regroupe bowling laser
game karaoké salles de concerts bars
restaurants des activités pour petits et
grands sont ainsi proposés en cette
période estivale c'est l'occasion de
passer un bon moment en famille ou entre
amis comme ces jeunes qui sont venus ici
pour décompresser après une année
compliquée on était venu avec un ami on
attendait d'eux d'autres copains et des
copines mais du coup bas en actions d'un
film d'une partie de billard en
attendant voilà on est entre amis on est
tous ensemble on s'amuse bien on n'est
pas venu là le sort ou bien que la la
journée mais je pense que ça peut être
sympa c'est très sympa on profite bien
des vacances suite aux dernières
annonces du président de la république
le pass sanitaire sera nécessaire pour
accéder à ces différents équipements le
responsable du site comprend cette
mesure qui ne sera pas sans contraintes
il devra notamment embaucher de nouveaux
salariés contrôlés les clients bien sûr
c'est compliqué la situation est
compliquée pour tout le monde pour tous
les commerçants on va faire ce qu'il
faut on va on va contrôler on va mettre
du personnel pour que ça se passe bien
que qu'on n'ait pas de kloster qu'on
n'ait pas de qu'on n'ait pas de gens
contaminés
ce my world c'est le lieu qui vous donne
le sourire alors si vous voulez
entre amis en famille ou même sous sol
n'hésitez pas en tout cas pour moi la
décision d'eric prise je crois que je
vais rester ici encore un peu pour
profiter de toutes ces activités
une petite partie de bowling ne me
ferait pas de mal c'est parti
[Musique]